je rêve d'aller en bord de mer avec une
fille l'enlacer met la main dans ses
cheveux et lui dire à quel point je
l'aimais je suis là dans mon bureau à
faire des vidéos à les fils et filles
quelle grande complexité comment faire
passer le filet comment se mettre en
valeur
comment s'y prendre avec quelqu'un du
sexe opposé ou du même sexe tout ça
c'est l'école de la vie on apprend de
nos erreurs on apprend nous-mêmes et on
avance il n'y a pas de leçons à suive
pas d'instructions pour réussir du moins
c'est ce que je pensais ce jeu s'appelle
super cdu soeur ses remèdes qui nous
donnent des cours mais vraiment des
cours pour nous apprendre à plaire aux
filles alors souvent ce genre de truc
c'est hyper me auger l'hyper cliché est
hyper gênant bord super seducer c'est
parti c'est des vidéos dans la vraie vie
il ya des situations c'est un jeu à
choix on va choisir achètent parce qu'il
doit faire et nous dira ah bah non là tu
as tort il fallait pas faire ça c'est
parti wacom substitut été fantastique le
petit sourire du mec qui vient
d'encaisser l'argent que j'ai mis pour
avoir le jeu alors alors alors ça
commence par accoster une fille dans la
rue je sens que ça va être horrible d'un
autre côté je vais apprendre à se dire
des femmes et sans ce mec est ce je
n'arriverai jamais dr imad ces partis
allons-y
[Musique]
il est 6 heures d'élise au g1 ça m'a
surpris [ __ ] a b c d e f quoi y'a trop
de choix et ce qu'on approche
directement de devant est ce qu'on
approche un peu de côté et ce qu'on fait
semblant d'être aveugle moi je dirais
qu'il faut faire semblant d'être aveugle
quand même dans cette situation je veux
dire en plus c'est très éthique
[Musique]
ok alors on y va en phase iia la musique
succèdent pour shaw arrière quand tu
toucheras bonne explication d'un coup il
ya deux mois un poil à côté en tout cas
c'est bien il considère pas du tout la
femme comme un objet le but ce n'est pas
de finir dans un lit avec des femmes en
sous vêtements non non non c'est de
créer vraiment une relation sympa après
j'ai mon esprit curieux qui a envie
d'aller au bout de ce truc alors
maintenant qu'on l'a arrêté et qu'on a
deux femmes à poil dans notre lit qu'est
ce qu'on lui dit je t'ai vu et je veux
juste te dire que tu es très élégante
hatay minutes c'est pas déjà vus à mes
cours de yoga se trouve très belle
j'aimerais qu'on attendait toi et moi
maintenant est ce qu'on n'est pas allé
au même collège tous les deux dit que tu
veux vfi ses boucles d'oreilles comme
excuse pour avoir un contact avec elle
trouve une excuse pour retirer ton
t-shirt pour le traité plus de demandes
lui quelques coupes de cheveux tirés
bien ah bah oui mais ça qu'il faut faire
gober ça tombe bien ça ton tellement
maire a bon maintenant que je sais
séduire une fille dans la rue c'est bien
mais moi j'ai souvent soirée je veux
savoir séduire des femmes en soirée
aubin deux belles filles sont en train
de boire du vin le but avoir un numéro
voir comment tu fais le premier pas on a
paré de derrière le sofa
c'est pourquoi je lui dois la dessus moi
bordel on leur demande de nous aider à
choisir un cadeau pour un ami son regard
elle est vénère elle veulent planter
j'en peux plus ça me dérange trop là
désolé les amis on sera pas séduire des
filles en soirée qu'elle d'aumale ah là
là on est tous triste vraiment le niveau
suivant qu'est ce que ces mecs dies je
priais pour que cela c'est pour ça que
jamais en soi quand on fait cette fille
nous plaît [ __ ] mais qu'est-ce qu'on
fait bordel to work attaque
[Musique]
voir qu'est ce qu'on fait [ __ ] pas
dormir seul ce soir bordel alors on fait
un bon rôle
[Musique]
l'aqua mundo au cul les batailles comme
tu danses la presse j'ai jamais fait de
moonwalk en soi et je demande et lui ce
qu'elle aime faire à ses heures perdues
[Musique]
yes yes suis plus objectif j'ai juste
envie qu'ils se fassent reculer tout le
temps bon tout ça c'est beau mais alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait on lui demande si
elle veut s'asseoir parce qu'elle doit
être fatigué d'avoir dansé depuis si
longtemps est ce qu on lui met la main
dans les cheveux et qu'on lui dit
qu'elle a de petites oreilles mignonne
et secours hier sa bouche pendant
qu'elle part on lui dit qu'elle nous
plaît vraiment et qu'on aimerait
l'embrasser où on lui attrape les fesses
bon à faire du complément sur les
oreilles ok c'était les oreilles fallait
on a réussi à danser un peu avec à la
faire s'asseoir à parler on se connaît
un peu mieux on lui suggère de venir
chez nous j'avais jamais chez une
inconnue comme ça alors je suis un mec
mais je le ferai quand même pas puisque
je suis un mâle très peu alpha oui on
lui demande si elle a déjà fait l'amour
dans le vestiaire d'un club
vous avez vu mon corps réagit on lui
demande si elle voit quelqu'un
[Musique]
c'est lourd bon alors la suite est-ce
qu'il est temps de lui dire que on
connaît un endroit avec de la meilleure
musique et du bon vin à cas chez nous ce
qu'elle va percuter alors du résultat on
a eu son numéro on n'a fait que 50% de
choix correct ça on passe clairement pas
assez de temps soirée à essayer de
séduire des femmes alors n'est que ce
niveau c'est quoi de zinc à fond temps
différent en vraie ville d'auch y a rien
derrière le rideau tu fais une sorte de
vidéo tuto pour aux arts comment aborder
une fille dans un café mais dans le café
ya que l es tu toi c'était pas ça la
vraie vie au starbucks gros y'a pas que
toi une fille à l'insuline chez aurel
passé dans les premières phrases que tu
peux dire à la fille a encore le coût du
doigt faire un cadeau à une amie est ce
que tu peux m'aider et gros il a réussi
à sortir avec une femme dans sa vie la
première fois qui lui a parlé c'est
grâce à cette phrase s'accroche depuis
il s'en passe plus gros enfin je suis en
train d'apprendre souvient des femmes
vous pouvez pas faire ça les gars vous
pouvez pas faire ça bah c'est une blague
mais je suis au piège légal très loin il
est temps qu'on l'attend on peut se
poser mais on voulait vous de vous
annoncer qu'on serait pas fait que tu
l'as vu tu lui as demandé des conseils
pour offrir un cadeau à un ami c'était
comme ça que vous attendez donc le jeu
ça marche bien je trouve ça commence à
être un poil on l'a prise demain
là on commence à transpirer un poil et à
mélanger nos sens oui et c'est agréable
pour moi je sais que du plaisir
regardez bien il ya un petit point
commun entre cette même j'émettrais
les cheveux aucun de nous trois mais
parsemé au coeur de toile un début de
calvitie
tu sais que par contre j'avais pas le
terrain des buts de kalou voire pas du
tout tourne toi et regarde simple c'est
magique on arrête plus tard jack
championnat prend la subir des tables
regardez ça c'est ce que j'ai pour les
télés et tous et pour les vidéos à tampa
bay au poivre de cheveux vesta vraiment
zéro je veux jeu là c'est pour ça que ça
marche pas il en a il y en a beaucoup
quand même pas pour un problème pour les
amis c'était la petite interlude
calvitie fit au lit et carlito bon nous
en arrivons au tutoriel pour qu'une amie
devienne votre petite amie
mais il écrit pied que ses amis gros
comme si je veux ça comment faire le
tuto commencé cet ami vous envoyer oh
mon dieu les mecs sont vraiment des
connards j'ai besoin de te parler tout
de suite qu est ce qu on fait comment
allons nous faire pour que cette fille
devient notre petit film c'est pour que
cet ami devienne autre petit ami qu on
répond immédiatement avec un je suis là
pour toi on attend un petit peu avant de
répondre à ça on connaît bien il faut
toujours attendre pour faire un peu mal
alfaro montrer qu'on n'est pas au pied
de quiconque ne l'exclus ce que j'ai à
dire bonjour que c'est un peu plus
intelligent qu'est ce que tu fais
pourquoi tu réponds pas répondre désolé
j'étais occupé tout va bien pour
répondre désolé j'étais occupé à faire
ça et lui envoyer une photo d'eux on lui
répond bien évidemment désolé j'étais
occupé tout va bien elle répond qu'elle
a besoin de te parler et de te voir ce
soir
oui oui j'en ai la tête voir courir
jusqu'aux yeux frères attendez attendez
ok cela il va chercher un truc on ramène
de bouteilles de champagne on les ramène
du vin on les ramène un arbre meiway
[ __ ] voilà c'est ça le secret pour
patrice tapé de rupture il te faisait
son truc c'était pas du tout un art moi
je veux tu ramènes un vrai rebond thuram
nhn gêne c'est elle qui a rompu c'est
pas lui à c'est pour ça qu'elle est
venue en mode sur son trente-et-un bien
maquillée tous apparemment toujours
quand tu fais une rupture tu te mets pas
comme ça tu es en combi de ski frère tu
sais pas pourquoi tu as métriques de
plus à l'aise et le plus chaud que tu
avais sous la main étaient là comme ça
c'est pas ses amis sont là pour toi au
volet dit qu'elle a bien fait alors il
se passe quoi alors la titille à la
chatouille je croyais en la beauté
maintenant l'achat de tout analyser ya
juste eu des guilis là tu vas pas de
faire une certes à sion sur les guides
et [ __ ] gros à la fin il se passe quoi
seuil en arrive au point on peut faire
genre qu'on se bat et l'embrassé
m
sa technique pour sortir de la fredzone
s'étaient déguisés est ce que quelqu'un
te vends cette vidéo est déjà sorti de
la fredzone en faisant des guilis non
les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur
cette vaste connerie qu'est ce jeu
n'hésitez pas à aller mais ciel vous a
plu la vidéo pas le jeu [ __ ] vous
mettez pas de pression pareil quand une
fille vous plaît n'y a pas de méthodes
mathématiques appliquées et je dis ça je
suis pas du tout un mec qui gérera point
que les filières mais par contre je sais
que je ferai jamais ça court terme le
mec qui fait des mathématiques en tout
cas je vous souhaite de rencontrer
l'amour en avoir du succès auprès des
hommes ou des femmes ou des deux faites
ce que vous voulez avec votre cul tout
vous appartient c'est vos organes
génitaux c'est votre cerveau c'est votre
corps mais par pitié l'appliqué pas des
méthodes plus au filet et si vous vous
plantez c'est pas grave on apprend de
ses erreurs on avance on s'en fout allez
je vous fais des bisous je retourne
faire des effets concours de majorettes
[Musique]
je vous dis à bientôt en tuant les
zigotos lolita au foot j'ai commencé un
café
[Musique]